[Music]
I've learned so much about life about
being a good person if not for you guys
that be back on the Thal just waiting to
be rested like everyone else
Ezra you have never been like everyone
else trust yourself trust the force I
could see what they were thinking
you must have established a deep
connection the force is trying to tell
you something listen to it we have hope
hope that things can get better
and they will
[Music]
is it wrong for me to protect my friends
how did I come to it
the question is fighting for the people
your voice started something that
something has grown bigger than I ever
imagined we can do this together let's
go get Hera you're in terrible trouble
[Music]
I've seen you before to tell you
something I hate your hair
let's go rebels
full-scale bombardment of the city
is a media mine at last
I know what we have to do now
one last lesson
something does not complement the circle
is now complete so we have to freak out
about this if you guys didn't know this
is the final season of Star Wars rebels
it's really like the second half of the
final season but because of the way they
break episodes up it feels like a whole
different season it was an article that
was published that was a little
misleading making it sound like all the
episodes were gonna be two hours long
but what's happening when the show comes
back February 19th these are just airing
episodes back-to-back so it's gonna be
like the rest of the season over a
couple of weeks then the finale is 90
minutes three episodes back-to-back so
you won't have to wait that long there
won't be any big cliffhangers between
the last couple of episodes and if you
were confused by what was going on with
Ezra talking to the convoy al in the
astral plane they are very clearly
pushing into the mortis arc from Star
Wars Clone Wars or bringing that back
what's that
[Music]
are you the one hello who are you I am
done a family in balance the light and
the dark day with night destruction
replaced by creation and why reveal
yourselves to us there are some who
would like to exploit our power the Sith
but one too much dark or light would be
the undoing of life as you understand it
you know on top of all that mortis
they're teasing a big confrontation with
Emperor Palpatine they actually got the
actor from the movies to come do the
character for the animated series so
when you hear him speak during the
trailer is just like them getting James
Earl Jones to come to animate at Darth
Vader for the series like he says one
last lesson and it looks like he's
talking to a hologram the way they cut
the trailer is meant to imply that he
has one last lesson and that lesson is
going to be the confrontation with
Palpatine like in the way that this is
all proceeding the original trilogy they
also do callbacks to the original
trilogy moments Luke has one final
lesson he has to confront Vader in the
Emperor tries to turn his father into
the really badass shop with Ezra in
front of those loathe wolves if you
haven't been watching Star Wars rebels
this final part of the season is pushing
heavy into force mythology they do that
a lot with the animated series so if you
were disappointed by the way that last
Jedi treated force lore or did not treat
it like the only very briefly touched on
some big force concepts with a couple
big twists they actually take the time
to explain a lot of that during the
animated series in a lot of you were
asking you know what's gonna happen
because Star Wars rebels is going off
the air are they gonna do another TV
show because there's a live-action Star
Wars TV show but that was just announced
it's not supposed to premiere til the
end of 2019 on the Disney streaming
service so like Disney has their own
version of Netflix they're developing
where all their content is probably
gonna go in a couple years but that's
still a ways off that's not gonna happen
for a while
behind the scenes Dave Bologna is
supposedly building another animation
team you know people are coming to
Lucasfilm to do another animated series
but we don't know any
about it we just know that there's gonna
be another Star Wars animated series
after Star Wars rebels we don't know
what time period it's gonna be set
during it could be the continuing
Adventures of broom boy it could be set
during the original trilogy it could be
set during present day during the events
of the new trilogy there were rumors a
long time ago that they were gonna do a
series set during the new trilogy but I
think they want to avoid stepping on the
toes of what JJ Abrams is gonna do with
episode 9 so early prediction if it's
not set during the events of the
original trilogy they'll set it between
the events of episode 6 in episode 7 so
if you're hoping for more force lure
more Snoke more new stuff we might get
that with this new animated series but
that's also speculation at this point
they probably won't reveal any details
till Comic Con this summer but I'm sure
Dave Filoni will start doing interviews
really soon but the sort of backdoor
confirmation that this gives us is that
Dave Filoni is not going to be show
running the live-action Star Wars TV
show in a couple years we still don't
know anything about that but I'm
expecting it to work like a lot of the
animated series do where you have a
mixture of new characters familiar
characters and they just give it the
time to build out force lore and the
really cool things that the films don't
have time for like in last Jedi you see
Luke project himself across the galaxy
but in a TV series you get to see people
like Ezra interacting with people like
the daughter and maybe the father too
like this is probably the avatar of the
daughter because she has that green cast
to her the avatar of the owl implies
some sort of wisdom some sort of
guidance that it's giving towards him so
it just makes sense that the daughter
representative of the light side of the
force is going to usher him on the next
stage of his journey as he gets ready to
confront the Emperor
[Music]
but just let me know in the comments
what do you guys think about this and if
you haven't been watching rebels I would
recommend that you at least check the
last couple of episodes out then you can
go back and watch the rest of the series
thrones a total badass maybe we'll find
out after the finale where he was during
the events of the original trilogy in
where Ezra was for that batter like
where these force user characters are
they just roaming the galaxy are they on
the astral plane have they ascended to
force ghost status because I'm pretty
sure they're not allowed to step on the
toes of the Canon of the original
trilogy meaning that you have to explain
that Ezra went off somewhere else and is
doing something else during the course
of episodes 4 5 & 6 but if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos obviously I'll do videos
for the last couple of episodes I don't
normally do rebels videos because people
don't watch it that much week to week
people tend to binge it a little bit
more but just post all your video
requests in the comments below there are
a couple other videos that I'm working
on olan Rogers new animated series is
premiering next week so I'll do a
trailer video for that it's very much in
the vein of Rick and Morty
they have this crazy cast list these are
some of the bigger actors that they have
so I'll do a video about that next that
I have some new Avengers infinity water
that I'll post tonight while you wait
for everything click here for brand new
flash and click here for brand new black
panther thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight